but what is biden though he just goes
along and he kind of makes these things
up as he goes
you tell he was grasping for the issue
he didn't even understand really the
question
and he does this on all issues you know
there's an answer that joe biden gave
on a matter of uh same-sex marriage
redefining marriage a while ago because
joe biden for most of his career
supported the traditional definition of
marriage and then around 2012 he decided
to flip on this and then he wanted to
pretend that he's always been
super duper gay i don't he's been very
much in favor of gay rights and
redefining marriage and all these things
so he's given this answer he's repeated
it a lot on the campaign trail
and something about it just doesn't
sound quite right i saw these two men in
the corner when i was getting out of the
car
both well-dressed men in suits lean up
and kiss one another
and then go their separate ways one went
to the hercules building and one went to
the dupont building
and i turned and looked at my dad just
looked at me said joey it's simple
they love each other it's simple joey
they love each other
what prompted me i let the president
know that
i uh i did not have to evolve at all
i was and uh my wife
my sister all of us we were way
not ahead but we it was never thought to
be a problem with us
that never happened i can tell you i
would bet the farm
i would bet every dollar to my name that
did not happen
two guys in the 1960s in the middle
of the center of delaware did not kiss
one another
because in those days it was
not publicly acceptable to do that and
they wouldn't have done even the guys
might have lived together might have you
know
sort of done whatever wouldn't have
happened in public and i promise you joe
biden's dad didn't say sonny
you know so you see this perfectly
choreographed moment so that you can use
on the campaign trail 60 years from now
joey they love each other joe no i bet i
something tells me
joe biden's dad who was born what in
like the late 19th century or something
early 20th century was not this like
open-minded liberal guy was like god
joey you know
this is great and in 2012 you should
come out and
defend gay marriage even though you'll
vigorously oppose it for your entire
career but then you can remember this
moment joey
those guys love each other it didn't
happen and joe biden lies about these
things all the time don't forget he had
to drop out of the 1988 presidential
race because he was a liar
he lied he's lied about horrible
personal events he lied about
the driver who got into a car accident
with his wife
this tragedy when his wife died he lied
about that guy
and after the guy died a guy felt so
horrible about it for his whole life and
then after the guy died he maligned him
based on nothing and said
that he was a drunk driver the atlantic
even called joe biden out on this story
so here's what joe biden could say you
could say yeah you know look i'm a
product of my age and i kind of don't
really have any beliefs but i went along
with it and so yeah
i opposed homosexuality for most of my
career and then i was okay with
homosexuality but i
supported uh i opposed redefining
marriage and then around 2012 i changed
my mind because it was more politically
expedient and i supported redefining
marriage and that's my career
and you'd say okay well that's true of a
lot of politicians so that's fine
whatever you know okay no big deal
but instead he's got to lie and say oh
yeah me man i was
i was dancing to the village people back
in 1962 at the ymca like no you weren't
joe biden you weren't doing that
and none of that is credible which is
why when he gives answers on anything
forget
you know transiting the kids or or gay
marriage or whatever i mean when he
gives answers on taxes when he gives
answers on anything
you can't believe it because the guy has
no
principles i hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the michael knowles show be
sure to check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]